[Music]
the english language is strange when
it's raining cats and dogs we're not
literally talking about freak
meteorological events unusual sayings
like this one are everywhere and many of
them have truly bizarre origins did you
know that going berserk may have come
from viking war rituals and out of the
frying pan into the fire could be about
burning someone at the stake
if you want to know the unusual stories
behind our common expressions well
you're in the right place in this video
let's look at some more curious origins
of popular sayings
going cold turkey
why is quitting something suddenly
cooled going cold turkey what do these
birds have to do with kicking an
addictive habit this saying comes from
victorian london it can be found in a
satirical magazine which includes a
fictional story about a man who wrote a
relative out of his will after she
served him a cold turkey for christmas
soon the phrase emerged giving someone
the cold turkey treatment it was related
to the idea of cutting someone off
entirely but curiously today is used in
the context of addictive substances like
alcohol or drugs although no one is
quite sure how it made this jump
give a man a fish and you fed him once
teach mad fish and you fed him for a
lifetime
this proverb is about the value of
learning a new skill and how it
encourages self-reliance there's a
common misconception to this one that it
came from ancient china although many
proverbs are indeed attributed to
chinese philosophers this one is not one
of them instead it is neither ancient
nor was written by a man it first
appears in an 1819 novel by british
author ann isabella ritchie in her book
mrs diamond one of the characters says
quote if you give a man a fish he is
hungry again in an hour if you teach a
man to catch fish you do him a good turn
the myth that this saying is from
ancient china seems to have sprung up in
the 1960s the first to have made this
claim was an american magazine the
rotarian and it popularized the idea
that this came from the far east
since then the assumption has stuck
it's raining cats and dogs
this expression is used to describe
heavy rainfall like really heavy
rainfall as with a lot of phrases this
one came from jolly old england a nation
known for its miserable weather believe
it or not animals raining from the sky
is a documented meteorological
phenomenon but not with cats and dogs
but fish in the central american
republic of honduras there's a local
festival known as luva depeches
literally translating to fish rain in
the wet months of may and june fish
actually fall from the sky to which the
locals welcome with a carnival
scientists have documented this bizarre
natural phenomenon and have discovered
that it's a result of water spouts small
tornadoes that develop over water
they're able to pick up water and scoop
any unfortunate marine knife in their
path and then rain them both down onto
nearby land
okay we've established that raining fish
is actually a thing but what about cats
and dogs there are no reported cases of
this actually happening no tornadoes are
sweeping through pet stores at least as
far as i'm aware
turns out the whole reigning cats and
dogs thing has a completely separate and
unrelated story behind it some
folklorists say it came from norse
mythology where odin's dogs gary and
frecky were able to summon the wind
at the same time it was understood that
cats could magically influence the
weather
especially rain so raining cats and dogs
could mean that it's both windy
and rainy personally i'm not so sure
about this one it's raining rain and
wind
perhaps not also the descendants of
norse languages today have their own
uniquely strange idioms for bad weather
in swedish it's raining little devils
in norwegian it's raining she trolls and
my favorite danish it's reigning
shoemaker's apprentices thank you
scandinavia you never fail to amaze
okay let's get back on track another
leading theory is that it's actually
based on a greek expression in greek to
say something is beyond belief it's
catadoctor so if it's raining outside
like you won't believe it's raining
catadoxa
some linguists believe that the english
speakers misunderstood this greek word
and catadoxa mutated somehow into cats
and dogs
as it stands no one quite knows the
origin of this saying so let's take a
rain check on this one for now
with great power comes great
responsibility if the origin of this one
seems familiar to you then you may be a
fan of spider-man these are the famous
last words that uncle ben uttered to
peter parker although when it first
appeared in 1962 it was spoken by the
narrator
this saying has become so tied with the
marvel superhero that has been nicknamed
the parker principle however this
memorable saying about the
accountability of power was actually not
devised by spider-man's creators stan
lee and steve ditko instead it has a far
longer history they may have got it from
u.s president franklin d roosevelt who
in 1945 said quote in a democratic world
as in a democratic nation power must be
linked with responsibility
two years prior in 1943 british prime
minister winston churchill uttered a
very similar phrase quote the price of
greatness is responsibility
but he in turn may have borrowed it from
a french revolution address where in
1793 it was declared that where there is
power there must also be responsibility
this memorable phrase is intertwined
with the rise of democracy in the
western world so how spider-man's uncle
ben got all the credit is quite the
mystery
go berserk
to go berserk is to get angry
this word came to english from the
vikings and was originally reserved for
the most ferocious warrior of all the
berserker
the sagas tell us that before a battle
these warriors would enter a frenzy
trance they'd foam at the mouth yell
furiously and be unable to tell friend
from foe
other legends tell us that these
berserkers were even capable of reaching
superhuman strength believed to be
immune to both fire and steel
viking historians have suggested that
these warriors were able to enter such a
state through a type of ritual that
induced a manic hysteria
others say that they may have consumed
psychedelic substances like certain
mushrooms or seeds alternatively others
have simply said that they just drank so
much beer and they were off their faces
the entire time
interestingly where go berserk came from
scandinavia the related phrase running a
mock may have come from the far east a
mark is indonesian in origin it's a word
used to describe a sudden outburst of
violence in many folk religions it was
said that the demon tiger hantu bellian
had possessed the person and caused them
to go mad forgetting who they were and
what they were doing british explorer
captain james cook once documented an
instance of a mock he described how man
once went about quote killing and
maiming villagers and animals in a
frenzied attack
the word amok then entered the english
language and was used to describe
chaotic individuals
avoid like the plague the meaning of
this phrase is pretty simple is all to
do with staying away from something or
someone at all costs for most of human
history there's one disease that
everybody wanted to avoid the bubonic
plague for victims painful sores known
as buboes would erupt on the body if the
disease entered the bloodstream then
death would swiftly follow
the first person to write this phrase
down was possibly saint jerome after
translating the bible into latin he
offered this advice quote avoid as you
would the plague a clergyman who was
also a man of business
fortunately for saint jerome he never
actually had to live through a plague
epidemic it would be roughly 120 years
after his death when the roman empire
under justinian suffered a horrific
outbreak of bubonic plague spreading
across the mediterranean and possibly as
far as china this plague is believed to
have killed anywhere between 15 to 100
million people
but this was dwarfed by another outbreak
some 800 years later the black death
between 1346 to 1353
the same disease believed to have come
from central asia this time killed
roughly 75 to 200 million people
worldwide claiming the lives of a third
of medieval europe's population
you can see why this phrase a void like
the plague caught on and spread it first
appeared in english in 1647
shortly before another devastating
bubonic plague was to break out in the
city of london
nowadays whilst global pandemics are
certainly not behind us it's perhaps
reassuring to know that bubonic plague
is now treatable with antibiotics
out of the frying pan
into the fire
from one dark saying to another this
phrase is used when something goes from
bad to worse it's believed to have come
from reformation england and may be to
do with burning people at the stake it
first appeared in a heated religious
debate between catholic theologian
thomas more and protestant reformer
william tyndale thomas moore argues that
his rival has dabbed himself to hell
with his controversial statements he
writes that his opponent has quote by
his false reproach of trickery conveyed
himself out of the frypan into the fire
in other words such blasphemy would not
only land you on a burning stake but
also land you in the fires of hell
but why frying pans
well there was a contemporary christian
belief that one of the many ways that
demons tortured people in hell was by
cooking them in a giant frying pan
now i know it sounds a bit strange but
it was a genuine fear held at the time
if you've ever read dante's inferno
you'll know that there are a lot more
strange punishments out there
so out of the frying pan and into the
fire only issue with this one is that it
really should be the other way round
from the fire the steak into the frying
pan hell
either way in the end william tyndale
really did end up being burnt at the
stake but this was only after henry viii
beheaded thomas moore to mix my
expressions i guess you could say that
he got a taste of his own medicine
well there you have it another
collection of stories behind some of our
most popular sayings we've covered a lot
of ground from berserk vikings to
bubonic plagues if there are any sayings
that you'd like to see covered let me
know down in the comments below
in the meantime consider checking out my
previous video on this very topic
but for now i think we'll leave it there
although there are still plenty more
sayings out there just waiting to be
explored
hey thanks for watching i really hope
you enjoyed this one
there were so many interesting sayings
left from the last video that i just had
to make a follow-up even still there's
plenty more left in the tank
if you'd like to see more why not
subscribe a like and a comment also go a
really long way
anyway i look forward to seeing you next
time
goodbye
[Music]